tarder commencer notre audition en vous
remerciant d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation de cette mission
d'information qui est conduite au niveau
de la commission des affaires
économiques à la demande du président du
Sénat sur la crise du logement bien sûr
le constat mais surtout quelles sont les
réponses qu'on peut y apporter qu'ell
soi conjoncturell structurelle et puis
nous souhaiterions aussi au vu des des
des auditions que nous avons conduit et
que nous conduiront jusque grosso modo à
la mi-mars peut-être être force de
propositions sur des propositions qui
sont peut-être un peu plus innovante
voire disruptive pour apporter des
solutions à cette crise du logement qui
est une crise particulièrement grave
donc nous avons commencé nos auditions à
la mi-décembre et nous pensons terminer
pour rendre notre rapport à la mi-mars
et en fonction ensuite de la
présentation du rapport en commission
euh soit on déclinera une partie des
propositions dans une proposition de loi
soit initialement on avait pensé aussi
peut-être intégrer certaines des
propositions dans le grand projet de loi
logement que nous annoncé l'ex-ministre
alors je dis pas je sais pas si l'ex
futur ministre mais en tout cas l'ex
ministre du Logement qui était annoncé
pour le mois d'avril 2024 pour autant on
pense qu'aujourd'hui alors qu'il n'y a
plus de mise du logement et quand bien
même il serait renommé en nous espérant
en tout cas à la fin de la semaine
prochaine
ça semble difficile le calendrier qui
était initialement prévu par rapport à
ce grand véhicule législatif sur le
logement donc nous conduisons cette
mission à à trois trois rapporteurs de
façon
transpartisane Amel gaker qui est donc
sénatrice du ptecalé pour le groupe
centriste VI Artigalas qui est sénatrice
des Hautes Pyrénées pour le groupe
socialiste et moi-même sénatrice des
Alpes Maritimes pour le groupe les
républicains et on est accompagné de
notre administrateur Mathieu Messonnier
donc nous sommes heureus aujourd'hu
aujourd'hui de vous accueillir vous êtes
deux chercheurs deux éminents chercheurs
l'un Jacques frégit et depuis de
nombreuses années vous êtes renommé pour
vos travaux historiques sur les prix du
logement et vous Monsieur François
Rochon Vous avez présenté votre thèse il
y a peu d'années donc votre dernier
livre qui est paru l'an passé qualifier
la politique du logement de politique
impossible j'espère que vous nous
permettrez de surmonter cette
affirmation au regard de vos travaux
respectifs je souhaite que vous puissiez
nous présenter votre analyse de la crise
ou des crises du logement dans le sens
où plusieurs phénomènes s'entremêlent
aidez-nous à ne pas être Myop en ne
voyant que l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
mais en allant chercher plus loin les
causes des difficultés que nous
rencontrons j'ai pu lire que la crise de
l'hiver
1954 prenait ses racines dans
l'insuffisance de constr conruction dans
l'entre de guerre et le blocage des
loyers décidé en
1914 ce que nous vivons en 2024 ne
prend-il pas ses racines au-delà même de
la crise que nous avons déjà vécu en
2008 notre objectif est également je
vous l'ai dit de formuler des
propositions pour apporter des solutions
structurelles nous avons l'intuition que
le logement pourrait être arrivé à au
bout d'un cycle économique mais aussi
d'un cycle idé olique ce qui est
peut-être la dernière réforme
conceptuelle celle voulue par Raymond
bar en
1977 à presque aujourd'hui 50 ans les
aides fiscales à l'investissement
locatif sont pratiqué depuis 40 ans n'y
a-t-il pas besoin non pas d'un nouveau
réglage des outils existants mais plutôt
d'une refondation il me semble enfin que
cette nouvelle politique du logement
doit s'appuyer sur plus que des slogans
rebattus ou des des punchlines auquels
nous sommes malheureusement trop
habitués de plateau télé tel que sevrer
le logement de la drogue fiscale ou
encore une surdépense publique pour une
inefficacité collective et encore les
dos du dormant qui justifie une gestion
qui est strictement comptable et
budgétaire mais qui ne propose aucune
vision avant de vous laisser la parole
pour que nous vous interrogions je vous
indique que cette audition est diffusée
en vidéo sur le site internet du Sénat
et sur les réseaux sociaux voilà d'ors
et déjà je vous laisse la parole je vous
remercie de vos interventions respective
et après je ne doute pas que nous aurons
un certain nombre de questions à vous
poser je ne sais pas lequel des d'entre
vous souhait commencer monsieur
frégit c'est à vous mettez votre micro
s'il vous plaît voilà c'est parfait
parfait je vous remercie donc nous nous
sommes entendu avec Monsieur Rochon je
commence un quart d'heure de
présentation un quart d'heure de
questions-réponse puis ensuite il prend
le relais
donc je vais vous parler de mon sujet
fétiche je vais vous parler du prix de
logement sur longue période mais je
crois que c'est c'est c'est très lié à
votre sujet car je pense que les
l'origine de la contraction des volumes
à laquelle on assiste actuellement
réside dans des événements survenus il y
a 20
ans bien
euh la diapo suivante s'il vous
plaît bien alors tout d'abord comme je
vous parler du prix des logements euh je
voudrais faire deux préalables bon la
première chose c'est quand on parle de
logement il y a toujours de prix le prix
du bien le prix du service le prix du
bien c'est le prix de vente du logement
et le prix du service c'est le loyer et
il faut parler des deux vous allez voir
que je vais vous parler beaucoup des
loyers au début je vais commencer par
les loyers bon deuxièmement on va
beaucoup parler de croissance des prix
quand on parle de croissance des prix il
faut bien distinguer deux choses il y a
la croissance du prix moyen et puis y a
l'inflation du prix et c'est différent
parce que imaginons que les logements
soient de plus en plus grands et bien on
va voir le prix moyen qui va augmenter
ter alors même que le prix d'un logement
de taille donnée reste constant donc
quand on parle d'inflation il faut
défalquer de la croissance du prix moyen
tout ce qu'on appelle des effets
structur donc c'est la taille la qualité
la localisation et vous allez voir que
ces effets sont considérables et que si
on ne prend pas garde on risque de tir
des conclusions complètement opposées de
la même constatation diapo suivante s'il
vous plaît je commence par les loyers
donc ici vous avez l'indice des loyers à
structure constante de Lig C en gros
c'est la composante loyer deanise des
prix et la consommation euh depuis 1965
est rapporté au revenu par ménage moyen
du Français moyen c'est complètement
horizontal il s'est rien passé pas
d'envoler bon donc c'est très sage et si
on regarde un tout petit peu plus près
euh en fait il y a eu ça reste valable
par exemple si on regarde le parc privé
en agglomération parisienne les petites
courbes sont presque toutes confondu
diapo suivante s'il vous plaît alors
quand on entend ça aussitôt ça doit
faire tilt quand on conna un peu le
logement parce qu'on sait bien que le
poids du loyer dans le revenu du
locataire a doublé en 50 ans donc est-ce
qu'il y a pas contradiction et bien non
il y a pas contradiction simplement on
compare des choses différentes donc à
droite vous avez le doublement du du
poids du loyer dans le revenu des
locataires puis à gauche cette courbe
horizontale donc on ne compare pas des
choses différentes parce qu'à gauche on
a l'indice des loyers à qualité
constante et à droite on a le loyer
moyen qui a augmenté beaucoup plus vite
je vais vous montrer je vais l'illustrer
tout à l'heure à cause des effets
et puis en bas à gauche on a le revenu
moyen du Français moyen alors qu'à
droite on a le revenu moyen du locataire
or les locataires se sont papéris
papérisé par rapport à la moyenne et ça
c'est un phénomène absolument
structurant si on veut comprendre ce qui
s'est passé les 50 dernières années
diapo suivante s'il vous plaît voilà
donc la courbe rouge la courbe bleue
c'est la courbe qu'on vient de voir tout
à l'heure horizontale alors ce serait
intéressant de discuter ce qui s'est
passé dans les années 70 un jour un
ministre mal' posé la question question
je savais pas répondre et depuis j'ai
appris la réponse bon mais on en a pas
le temps
donc cette cour est pratiquement
horizontale la courbe rouge c'est la
paérisation des locataires donc on voit
qu'en gros un locataire apporté à la
moyenne était avait un revenu 50 % plus
élevé en 1970 qu'aujourd'hui donc si
vous cherchez à vous loger dans une
ville où le prix moyen des logements le
revenu moyen pardon est 3000 € et bien
il y a 50 ans le locataire moyen il
gagnait 3000 € et aujourd'hui il gagne
2000 € c'est pas du tout la même chose
quand vous cherchez à vous loger avec
2000 € qu' avec 3000 € donc ça c'est
complètement structure ensuite en noir
vous avez les effets structures c'est le
loyer moyen rapporté à l'indice des
loyers et lui il a doublé bon
presque et donc quand vous combinez ces
deux effets il y a une forme d'effet de
ciseau hein et bien vous trouvez que le
poids du loyer dans le revenu des
locataires a plus que doublé
voilà diapo suivante s'il vous plaît bon
alors la baopérisation des locataires
euh généralement bon c'est on en parle
quand même mais en général on dir ah
c'est parce qu'il y a eu de l'accession
donc il y a eu un effet d'crémage les
locataires revenus élevés sont devenus
propriétaire et resplique les autres en
fait ça suffit absolument pas parce que
dans le même temps où la proportion de
propriétaires occupant augmenté de 11 %
entre 1970 et 2020 la proportion de
locataire est restée constante vous
allez me dire où est passé la différence
ben ce sont une troème catégorie qu'on
oublie généralement sur les logés
gratuitement qui ont quasiment disparu
voilà euh donc cette explication là ne
suffit pason et quand on analyse les
explications en fait une explication
très importante c'est la popularisation
des jeune qui a été
massive il y a eu beaucoup de travaux à
ce sujet notamment ces dernières années
quand on a parlé des retraites bon et
alors cette poérisation des locataires
elle est au cœur de la problématique
budgétaire de la politique de logement
parce que la politique de logement c'est
une politique qui est ciblée sur les
locataire aujourd'hui 84 % des fameux 40
milliards du logement vont au locataire
mais il y a 40 ans c'était déjà une
grosse grosse grosse majorité et donc la
politique logement est ciblée sur une
cible qui se popérise c'est une
politique sociale ciblée sur une cible
qui se poérise donc si vous arriver au
même niveau de d'efficacité je puis dire
ça coûte de plus en plus cher et à
l'opposé vous avez par exemple les
politiques à l'égard des personnes âgées
à cause de la revalorisation
considérable des retraites il y avait 2
millions de bénéficiaires du minimum
vieillesse en 1970 il y a plus que
500000 bénéficiaires de Lapa aujourd'hui
voilà diapo suivante s'il vous
plaît bien maintenant j'en arrive au
prix des logements donc sur cette diapo
vous retrouvez la courbe bleue c'est les
loyers c'est ce on par tout à l'heure et
voyz le prix des logement lui il a pas
évolué du tout de la même façon entre
1965 et 2000 il est resté à peu près
constant par rapport au revenu moyen par
par ménage entre 2000 et 2007 en fait
2002 et 2007 ça c'est passé vraiment en
5 ans il y a une explosion de 70 % et
depuis c'est à peu près constant on a
par rapport au revenus par ménage on a
bien toujours le revenu par ménage au
dénominateur bon alors la question
pourquoi diapo suivante si s'il vous
plaît donc euh quel qu'est-ce qui
explique cet envolie alors il y a une
explication qui est souvent avancée et
qui ne tient pas c'est l'explication par
le rythme de construction on naurait pas
construit suffisamment de logement et ça
expliquerait l'envolier de 70 % du prix
de logement par rapport au R venu
pourquoi est-ce que ça ne tient pas pour
deux raisons la première raison tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire qu' sil y
avait plus de logement toute chose égale
parilleur le prix serait plus bas c'est
la loi de l'offre et la demande toute la
question c'est de savoir de combien et
là il y a une bibliographie qui porte
sur ce qu'on appelle l'élasticité du
prix des logements par rapport à leur
nombre c'est la variation du prix des
logements lorsque le nombre de logements
augmente de 1 % toute chose égale par
ailleurs donc en France il y a 40
millions de logements imaginons qu'il y
en a 400000 de plus ilag de production
il y a 2 ans de combien est-ce que prix
logement serit plus bas toute une
bibliographie et qui concorde sur un ord
de grandeur de -1- 2 vent dit 1 % de
logement en plus ça fait 1 ou 2 % de
prix de logement moins donc vous voyez
que on peut absolument pas expliqué par
un raisonnement de ce type là le bon de
70 % du prix des logements qu'on vient
de voir sur la diapo précédente par
rapport au revenus bon et la deuxième
raison c'est que si une inadéquation du
rythme de construction avait causé
l'envolet des prix elle aurait dû avoir
un effet sur les loyers alors certes les
loyers sont encadrés mais le sont
surtout en cours de bail auou m du
renouvellement de bail les loyers à la à
la relocation en tout cas pendant la
plus grande partie de la période que
nous avons vu là était quand même
relatif
libre ils nont été ils n'ont été
restreints que sur une partie du
territoire or nous avons vu que la
courbe des loyers est complètement plate
complètement horizontal
voilà donc ce n'est pas une question de
rythme de la construction qui a causé
l'envolé du prix des logs alors
qu'est-ce que c'est bah parfois on
entend dire c'est la faute du prix des
fonciers qui est trop cher alors ici
c'est le problème de la poulée de l'œuf
est-ce que c'est le prix du foncier qui
entraîne le prix du logement ou est-ce
que c'est le prix du logement qui
entraîne le prix du foncier et bien ici
c'est le le prix du logement qui
entraîne le prix du foncier en vertu du
compte à rebour compte à rebour c'est
quelque chose que les promoteurs savent
très bien vous expliquer quand ils
entendent dire qu'un terrain est à
vendre ils se rendent sur les lieux ils
regardent le prix des logements dans le
voisinage ils imaginent le logement
qu'ils vont pouvoir construire ça c'est
leur métier pour qu'il se vendent bien
il détermine le prix des logements neuf
en fonction des prix des logements du
voisinage plus ou moins un certain prix
contenu des caractéristiques du logement
neuf bon ensuite ils enlèvent tout leurs
coût c'est ce qu'ils appellent le compte
à rebours et ce qui reste c'est ce
qu'ils sont prêts à payer pour le
terrain moins une certaine marge de
négociation ils vont voir le vendeur il
lui propose ce prix et si le vendeur de
terrain accepte et bien il y a
transaction donc il y a prix de
transaction autrement dit c'est bien le
prix des logements du voisinage qui
détermine le prix des terrains alors ici
il y a une ambiguïé c'est parce Queen
fait quand les promoteurs nous parlent
du prix des terrains ils nous parlent
souvent non pas du prix de transaction
de la transaction qui s'est passée le
mois dernier au cours de laquelle un
promoteur a acheté un terrain qui qui
lui permet de construire un logement
sortant au prix permettant de vendre
mais il parle du prix que le vendeur est
prêt à accepter et qui est élevé alors
donc en fait il y a un problème
d'adéquation entre ce que les vendeurs
sont prêts à accepter comme prix et ce
que le promoteur peut payer pour sortir
un logement compétitif contenu des
capacités d'achat des
ménages mais c'est bien l'effet l'effet
de causalité va bien du prix des
logement au prix du foncier pas
l'inverse sur les prix de transaction
alors qu'est-ce qui reste il ne reste
plus qu'une chose qui soit à l'échelle
du phénomène ben c'est l'ffet
inflationniste d'environnement financier
des 20 dernières années voilà donc il y
a évidemment la baisse des taux
d'intérêt mais il y a aussi
l'allongement de la durée des prêts qui
a été une catastrophe pour les ménages
je
revenir et puis la croissance de
l'endettement des
ménages une tolérance à l'égard de
ménages diapo suivante s'il vous plaît
donc pour résumer les les les 25 les 30
derni les 35 dernières années tout en
haut vous avez la courbe du prix de
logement rapporté au revenus par ménage
c'est celle que je viens de vous montrer
à l'instant on voit bien l'envoler entre
2002 et 2007 puis la stabilité en rouge
en dessous vous avez les taux d'intérêt
donc ils ont baissé mais vous voyez
quand même que la baisse des taux n'a
pas coïncidé avec l'envolé du prix des
logements les choses ne sont pas
exactement ne coïncide pas exactement
dans le temps alors en dessous vous avez
en rose une courbe que que que nous nous
aimons bien c'est la durée sur laquelle
il faudrait emprunter pour acheter le
même logement qui pouvait être acheté en
en en en emprunteront sur 15 ans en 2000
bon et on voit que cette durée au tout
début entre 2000 et 2004
resté compatible avec la durée constatée
qui la courbe noire et ensuite elle
s'est envolée
elle s'est envolée parce que l'envolé
des prix était sans commune mesure avec
la baisse des taux d'intérêt bon et la
même sortie du graphique hein
euh et on voit d'ailleurs qu'en dessous
en dessous on a quelque chose qui est
pas exactement le même le nombre de
transactions de logement ancien mais la
vitesse de rotation c'est que c'est le
nombre de transaction de logement ancien
divisé par le nombre de logements du
parc en gros c'est TR c'est à peu près 3
% par an ça veut dire que chaque année 3
% des logements à peu près en moyenne
sont vendus logements ancien mais ça
aussi et donc ce qu'on voit c'est quand
la courbe rose explose et ben évidemment
la courbe marron en dessous diminue
parce que les gens ont plus les ont plus
la capacité pour acheter é log bon et
alors ensuite miracle il y a une grande
crise
mondiale il y a une grande crise
mondiale importé en France qui n'était
pas d'origine domestique en France Griss
financière qui a fait que les autorités
financières au sens large c'estàd la la
Banque centrale
européenne mais aussi en France les
autorités qui ont la tutelle ont ouvert
les vannes ont ouvert les vannes pour
éviter un craque un craque
complet donc à partir de ce moment-là on
voit que les taux d'intérêt ont continué
à baisser euh et puis il y a eu d'autres
phénomènes qui qui ont qui on augmenté
la liquidité alors la baisse t c'est pas
tout à fait vrai voyez qu'il y a une
exception entre 2005 et 2000 2009 où les
taux remontaient les prix continu à
exploser donc là on savait que ça
pouvait pas durer on Savit que ça
pouvait pas durer et nous nous pensions
à l'époque qu' aurait un agistrement par
les prix et en fait il y a bien eu un
ajustement mais pas par les prix c'est
fait par les taux d'intérêt comme les
taux d'intérêt ont été àissés un niveau
très bas les prix ont pu l'éviter comme
comme on le voit sur le graphique du
haut
voilà alors pourquoi est-ce que les les
prix ont ement explosé entre 2002 et
2007 bien il y a probablement un
contreeffet du craque des technologiques
craque boursier savoir que les craqu
boursiers sont généralement suivis par
des envolés du prix du logement par des
bosses c'est c'est évidemment c'est pas
seulement des envolés ensuite après
l'envolé il y a une rechute donc c'est
une bosse ça n'a pas été le cas dans
pour le craque de l'Union Générale à la
fin du 9e siècle mais c'était un cas
très particulier ça a été le cas après
1927 il y a une bosse du prix des
logements à Paris au début des années 30
ça a été le cas entre 87 90 après le
craque de boursé de 87 ça a été le cas
après le craque des technologiques et
après le craque des subprimes bah quand
même les prix ne pouvaient plus
augmenter parce qu'il éent déjà très
haut mais au moins ils ont l'évité ce
crack a permis de l'éviter donc c'est
c'est il y a eu un effet de ce type là
qui est extrêmement difficile à mettre
en évidence parce que mesurer la
liquidité c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que de mesurer les taux d'intérêt les
taux d'intérêt vous avez sur le site de
la Banque de France tout est clair les
liquidités c'est plus compliqué voilà et
et donc s'il avait pas eu cette
administration des taux d'intérêt de
cette cette grande ouverture du crédit
et bien les prix serai vraisemblement
retombé dès 2010 et j'ai ajouter tout en
bas en tout petit et ça aurait été mieux
ça aurait été mieux du point de vue du
logement parce que aujourd'hui ben le
ménage pourrait emprunter sur 15 ans
pour acheter son logement
vraisemblablement vous pouvez passer à
la diapo suivante s'il vous plaît donc
conclusion la récente remontée des taux
d'interr n'est pas une
surprise on savait bien que les taux
administrés ça vous pouvez pas durer
éternellement les Tau administré
d'ailleurs pour nous qui n occuper de
logement ça ressemble beaucoup au loyer
administré puisque les taux d'intérêt
c'est les loyers c'est c'est le loyer de
l'argent hein mais euh donc je je
reviens à mon sujet donc la récente
remontée des taux d'intérêt n'est pas
une surprise elle a interrompu l'effet
inflationniste de l'environnement
financier en désolvabilisant les
accédents et en réduisant la
compétitivité du placement au logement
évidemment comme souvent en immobilier
les prix ne se sont pas ajusté
immédiatement à la baisse qui une
proportion élevée des
vendeurs environ la moitié pour les
logements anciens et davantage pour les
terrain battir ne sont pas pressés de
vendre et beaucoup d'entre eux
anticipent que les prix finiront par
remonter d'ailleurs l'histoire leur a
souvent donné raison malheureusement
c'est pour ça que c'est un phénomène aut
renforçant et donc il préfèrent attendre
dans le 9U il y a un effet
supplémentaire qui est la ha des C de
construction d'ù baisse des volumes et
puis avec des effets d'entraînement sur
quantités de d'activités qui vivent dont
les recettes sont indexées sur les
montants de transaction de logement donc
évidemment toutes les professions dont
la rémunération est indexée sur les
transactions il y a les départements qui
perçoivent des droits de mutation et
cetera alors si on fait tout un petit
peu de prospective et bien il faut faire
une prospective sur l'environnement
financier diapo suivante s'il vous
plaît donc en conclusion des phénomènes
peut-être trop souvent néglig négligé la
grande modération de l'inflation des
loyers en tout cas la croissance à
structure constante deuxièmement la
paupérisation des locataires malédiction
budgétaire de la politique du logement à
for thorie si en plus on veut améliorer
les conditions de logement c'est ce qui
s'est passé la qualité de logement c'est
beaucoup amélioré il a fallu payer à la
compenser à la fois la popérisation des
locataires et payer l'amélioration des
logements bon la faiblesseasticité du
prix des logements par rapport à leur
nombre si jamais quelqu'un que vous
auditionnez vient vous dire que si les
prix on augmentés c'est parce qu'on a
pas assez construit posez-lui la
question quelle est l'élasticité du prix
des logements par rapport à leur nombres
et écoutez sa réponse et faites-vous une
opinion je vous ai joint dans le petit
dossier une revue bibliographie à ce
sujet vous verrez que c'est très
concordant il y a deux références qui
sont en dehors de la fourchette moins à
moin 2 mais on sait pourquoi et on on
sait pourquoi on les retient pas ensuite
le compte àbour c'est bien le prix de
qui détermine le prix foncier
constructible et non l'inverse ensuite
pour la première fois j'ai introduit le
mot crise bon parce qu'on pourrait
pendant pendant très longtemps discuter
sur ce que c'est qu'une crise s'il y a
vraiment une nouvelle crise ou pas et
cetera la principale crise pour moi
c'est que il y a 2 ans il y a 2 3 ans le
ménage pouvait acheter à peu près le
même logement que ses parents avaient
acheté en
2000 contenu avec un revenu ayant cru
comme le revenu moyen par ménage
simplement fallait s'en Detter sur 23
ans au lieu de 15 ans alors dans la vie
d'un ménage ça n rien à voir quand vous
êtes accédant à la propriété
généralement vous avez entre 30 et 35
ans vous avez des enfants en bas âge
imaginons que votre fille est 3 ans que
vous empruntez sur 15 ans 15 ans plus
tard elle a 18 ans vous allez pouvoir
l'aider à pendant ses études puisque
vous allez retrouver une petite marge de
manœuvre si vous empruntez sur 23 ans
c'est absolument impossible bon puis le
dernier évidemment l'effet inflationist
de l'environnement financier depuis 2000
alors j'ai rajouté deux diapos à la fin
à la demande de votre administrateur sur
la fragilité des comparaisons
internationales c'est un sujet sur
lequel j'ai commis un rapport il y a peu
de temps je vous ai mis les les
coordonnées du rapport dans dans le
petit dossier je vous donner deux
exemples première question on va
comparer les aides personnelles au
logement en France et en Allemagne en
pourcentage du PIB et bien si je vais à
l'OCDE on vous dit qu'en France
çaappelle 0,7 % du PIB et 0,7 % en
Allemagne bon donc c'est autant en fait
c'est légèrement plus en Allemagne
d'près si vous allez chez Eurostat on va
vous dire qu'en France c'est 09 en
Allemagne c'est 03 donc çaappelle trois
fois plus en Allemagne bon alors dans ce
domaine nous avons la chance d'avoir une
bonne étude fouillée faite par Monsieur
Cheffer
euh qui qui a étudié à fond les aides
personn au logement en Allemagne et qui
nous laisse penser que c'est l'OCDE qui
a probablement raison
voilà alors évidemment il y a des tas de
problèmes de comptabilité qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle une aide au logement dans
les années 70 quand le quand le prix du
pétrole augmenté en France on a augmenté
les aides au logement c'est la solution
qu'on a pris pour compenser pour les
ménage à revenus la hausse du du prix
forfait de charge qui figure dans le
Barin aujourd'hui quand on est confronté
à la même chose on a créé un chèque
énergie qui évidemment ne rentre pas
dans les aides personnelles logement les
Allemands eux ont choisi l'augmentation
des aides personnelles logement les
Allemands depuis le début des années
2000 depuis les accords art ont
énormément augmenter les aides
personnelles au logement ils sont allés
à fond sur les aides personnelles au
logement financé par les collectivités
locales bon la dernière diapo s'il vous
plaît alors là la question c'est la
comparaison des dépenses publiques en
faveur du logement en France et en
Allemagne donc euh je vous ai
retranscrit un tableau fait par une ONG
euh j'ai actualisé légèrement à à 2021
c'est tout mais le reste est en changé
alors on se réfère à des nomenclatures
comptables qui s'appellent les cofog
c'est des nomenclatures
internationalement internationalement
connu bon alors la première ça dépense
en logement donc on voit 0,4 pour la
France 01 pour l'Allemagne ensuite il a
les équipements collectifs alors c'est
quand même bizarre dans une
comparaison euh dans une comparaison de
la dépense ver du logement des
équipements collectifs déjà est-ce que
les gymnases c'est vraiment euh du
logement je sais pasement il y a une
autre chose qui est très bizarre c'est
que c'est trois fois plus en France
qu'en Allemagne alors quand je vais en
Allemagne j'ai pas l'impression que les
équipements collectifs soient vraiment
négligé euh donc je me dis ici que d'une
part c'est non pertinent et d'autre part
c'est quand même douteux parce qu'il est
tout à fait possible que les équipement
collectif soit ailleurs et cetera la
Cour des comptes qui a qui a fait un
rapport il y a pas très longtemps dessus
dit que souvent dans dans ces dans ces
comparaisons les dépenses des
collectivités locales sont ises par
exemple est-ce qu'ils ont is les
dépenses des collectivités locales en
Allemagne qui comme vous le savez on un
rôle beaucoup plus important qu'en
France je sais pas mais il y a quelque
chose de très bizarre iciensite
l'alimentation en eau bah je dirais pas
que c'est du
logement l'éclairage public non plus
sauf pour les SDF
peut-être la RD dans le domaine du
logement des équipement collectif ça ça
se discute mais c'est nul donc ça pose
pas de problème et logement équipement
collectif non classifié ailleurs
on peut se poser des questions sur
pertinente mais c'est tout petit donc
quand j'ajoute tout ça on obtient 1,3 en
France 0,5 en Allemagne ça fa déjà 0,8 %
de
différence alors quand même si on si on
enlève le poste équipement collectif il
ne reste plus que 04 % de différence et
puis tout en bas il y a les aides
personnels au logement donc ici on
retient la la classification Eurostat
que je vous a indqué tout à l'heure donc
09 contre 03 et en fait nous avons tout
lieu de penser contenu des études
fouillé que nous avons que c'est à peu
près zéro d'où la colonne de droite qui
est l'écart qui reste quand on a corrigé
de tout ça B le 1,4 % devient 0,3 %. et
c'est pas fini car dans la manière de
comptabilité de comptabiliser les
dépenses euh il y a quelque chose on
peut difficilement faire autrement mais
qui qui qui est très gênant c'est que ce
qu'on considère comme une dépense est ce
qui est normal bon alors en Allemagne
par exemple il y a une disposition qui
consiste à pouvoir amortir les logements
amortir en tout cas le prix foncier des
logements mais comme c'est des droit
commun c'est pas considéré comme une
aide nous n'avons pas ça mais nous avons
des aides fiscales à l'investissement
locatif qui sont considérés comme des
aides vous avez deux dispositifs je je
ne me prononce absolument pas sur la
pertinence de ces dispositifs mais qui
ont un peu le même objectif qui ont le
même objectif mais dont l' est
comptabilité comme dépense et l'autre
non donc si onalysé de près ce 0,3 % qui
reste résiduel peut-être qu'on
trouverait encore des choses à creuser
voilà et donc quand on
alors quand on bon je pourrais vous
donner des exemples comme ça je vous ai
apparé pendant une heure j'ai rédigé un
rapport qui est plein de choses comme ça
mais la conclusion c'est quand même faut
être très très très très prudent et si
vous si quelqu'un vous parle de
comparaison internationale en vous
disant que la France dépense beaucoup
plus que l'Allemagne ben je vous invite
à demander la note de calcul à la
regarder de près à l'expertiser au vu de
ce que je viens vous montrer là
merci merci beaucoup monsieur frigit
pour cette présentation euh je vous
laisse la parole Monsieur
rochan Merci alors je pense mon approche
sera complémentaire de celle de Monsieur
frigit elle ne recours pas aux
statistiques elle développe plus elle
s'intéresse plutôt à interroger nos
cadres de pensée et la façon dont les
travail dont les travaillent les acteurs
du logement elle part de l'idée que la
question du logement implique une
pratique politique démocratique et pas
seulement technique à la recherche d'une
vision d'ensemble pour reprendre
l'expression de claud riant et où le
secteur du logement social peut jouer un
rôle important en terme de proposition
dans cet exposé je reprends point par
point les éléments qui m'ont été
communiqués dans la note de cadrage dans
une présentation volontairement assez
incisive pour contribuer au débat vous
m'interrogez sur la caractérisation de
la crise je dirais que l'élément
d'actualité que nous avons une crise
peut-être classique de l'immobilier le
marché est grippé par un retournement
brutal de conjoncture il y a un problème
économique indéniable c'est
certainemente d'une gravité assez
historique la spécificité de cette crise
est que l'État ne dispose plus de
contre-mesures puissantes immédiate de
la même manière qu'il
a été d'une certaine façon dépassé par
la crise sanitaire il y a un déficit de
marge de manœuvre et de
savoir-faire trois points à ce sujet
après la crise de 2008 contrait
efficacement l'hybridation entre le
secteur privé le secteur social avec
aujourd'hui la moitié de production de
logements sociaux en VEFA et les
pressions financières notamment avec la
RLS réduisent le potentiel
contracyclique du logement social
deièmement le niveau d'endettement
actuel du pays et là je dois rappeler
l'entretien que m'avait accordé monsieur
philippe Dallier au au Sénat qui était
très attentif à la fois les dépenses
publiques et aux questions de logement
rend extrêmement prudent l'usage de la
relance par la dépense publique en
particulier des dispositifs fiscaux je
dis pas qu'il faut radicalement les
remettre en cause d'un d'un revers de
main mais mais la situation globale est
tout à fait différente de celle qui
prévalait il y a 20 ans de même
l'allongement de la durée du volume des
crédits immobiliers du de la durée et du
volume des crédits mobiliers pour les
ménages comme l'a souligné monsieur
frigit lié à l'augmentation des prix la
baisse parallèle des taux sur les
dernières décennies rend impossible un
accroissement du taux d'effort et donc
c'est cela la réalité de la politique du
logement aujourd'hui et il faut
souligner que tous ces éléments
déterminants n'ont pas été explicitement
débatttu ils sont en fait la résultant
d'une politique très silencieuse sur ces
sujets comme toute crise nous sommes
donc face à un moment de retour à la
réalité des choses derrière l'apparence
d'un marché du du logement jusque la
dynamique en trompelœil ressort un
problème structurel ancien interne et
qui n'a pas été traité qui a été esquivé
un problème fondamentalement politique
et c'est cela qu'il nous faut
déconstruire prioritairement à mon sens
pour obtenir des propositions efficaces
je pense que c'est c'est possible
d'obtenir des propositions efficaces au
fond que voulons-nous en matière de
logement pour notre pays cette question
n'est pas un sujet mondain de
dissertation en artifice de
communication c'est un travail politique
à mener méthodiquement à l'instar de ce
que fait votre commission vous
m'interroger pour mettre en contexte
dans le moment présent un regard sur la
politique actuelle du gouvernement je
ferai un bref rappel historique Jacques
chabandelmas qui était premier ministre
à l'époque faisait déjà ce raisonnement
d'une surdépense publique pour une
inefficacité collective dans des termes
relativement proches je vous passe la
citation le problème de cette
considération générale est qu'elle
esquive les connaissances spécifiques
sur le sujet qui existe sur le logement
on parle souvent de d'approche
comptable monsieur frigit d'autre part a
montré combien l'usage des instruments
statistiques est une affaire délicate
qui sert bien souvent à justifier des
positions établies plutôt qu'à les
remettre en question à les réinterroger
c'est pourquoi il ne nous faut pas
seulement nous baser sur sur les
chiffres mais pouvoir dire aussi ce que
nous attendons ce que nous prévoyons ce
que nous préparons avec la politique de
logement dans des termes que chacun peut
que comprendre dans les termes du
citoyen de l'électeur souvent figure
oublié c'est le cœur du problème à mon
sens qui entraîne le reste de la machine
et au fond on ne sait plus où on va et
cela n'a pas toujours été le cas je
voudrais rappeler que Jacques Chirac en
son temps poséit le diagnostic la
fracture sociale et proposé de mettre de
l'oxygène dans le système avec le préato
zéro soit l'accession à propriété des
couches moyennes tout en procédant aussi
à des réquisitions on dir aujourd'hui
fluidifier la chaîne du logement avec
une attention à la cohésion sociale qui
se manifeste par la suite sous la
cohabitation par la loi SRU plus tard
Nicolas Sarkozi va plus loin en
proposant la France de propriétaire
cette aspiration semble largement
partagé par la population mais comme le
noté dans l'audition de Romain dans une
une une conférence que vous avez
organisé voilà Robin
Rivaton cela ne s'est pas traduit dans
les fait malgré les taux d'intérêt
historiquement faible c'est un problème
enfin François Hollande proposait
d'équilibrer cette politique de régul
cette politique par la régulation du
secteur locatif privé qui a fait débat
mais les outils aujourd'hui sont
soutenus par une grande part des élus
locaux on le voit la politique du
logement avait donc une direction
intelligible pour chacun et elle avait
cette vertu d'entraîner le secteur dans
alors dans une certaine stabilité et
surtout dans une cohérence qui permet
d'organiser le le secteur productif en
conséquence et il me semble que depuis
2017 le récit de la politique du
logement est en quelque sorte en panne
celui-ci procède beaucoup par effet de
retrait c'est un sujet privilégié de
réduction budgétaire parfois par rabot
donc
qui interprète peu les questions de fond
c'est un choc de l'offre qui n'est pas
advenu et monsieur frigit a montré que
ces effets d'offre fonctionnaient peu
sur les prix c'est une suppression de la
taxe d'habitation sans lien direct avec
avec le sujet ou une création de l'IFI
comme résidu de l'écief et non pas comme
un projet pour le logement récemment
monsieur vergrit allit jusqu'à remettre
en doute la pertinence d'une politique
nationale du logement au profit d'un
puissant mouvement de décentralisation
autrement dit depuis ces dernières
années nous sommes dans une époque
revendiquée de discrétion sur le sujet
discrétion démocratique dans laquelle la
question du logement se réduit un sujet
technique qui explique du reste
l'absence récurrente de ministre du
Logement ce choix politique a le grand
bénéfice de la constance il faut le le
reconnaître mais on peut regretter
parallèlement qu'il efface du débat
public un grand sujet de société et
c'est la conséquence est de mettre de
côté dans le débat les Français les
électeurs au profit d'un dialogue qui
est de plus en plus tendu entre les
acteurs du secteur et l'État on peut sen
rendre compte ce matin par la conférence
de presse de l'Alliance pour le logement
ainsi le gripage de la chaîne du
logement qui a été évoqué dans les
précédentes auditions se double d'un
grippage de la chaîne des acteurs en
amont qui se trouve au fond euh amené à
prendre des positions politiques ou à
des revendications qui n'étaient pas
dans la trad dans la dans leur tradition
de leur positionnement et qui au fond
les met en défaut sur des sujets qui ne
sont pas leur sujet privilégiés
d'expertise c'est sur ce point en fin
d'exposé que porteront mes proposition
au fond nous sommes avec des acteurs
très engagés très mobilisés mais sans
boussole politique et il est important
de compenser ce vide politique car ce
n'était pas leur rôle jusqu'à présent
ils sont amenés à se faire force de
proposition sur un registre qui n'est
pas le leur et force de constater que
les débats sont souvent mal posés vous
m' interroger sur un point de vue sur
les aides fiscales je dirais
qu'évidemment les acteurs sont plutôt
pour les aides et l'État plutôt
scrupuleux c'est leur rôle respectif la
controverse est inévitable et donc peu
productive en matière de de de
conception politique du du logement la
question me semble plutôt est-ce que
cela a fonctionné depuis les premiers
dispositifs au début des an 80 que vous
avez cité madame la Présidente la
réponse et clairement non en volume le
parc locatif privé a quasiment stagné
depuis les années 70 tandis que le
volume de l'accession a plus que doublé
et celui de logement social a triplé
dans le même temps un certain type de
logement qui a présenté 15 % en 70 qui
ces statut un peu particulierers loger
gratuit lui s'est considérablement
réduit oui nous av avons un problème
structurel sur le locatif privé et par
conséquent oui peut-être la
professionnalisation de cette activité
certainement une bonne piste le deuxième
point que vous soullignez est les
besoins en construction les acteurs
veulent construire beaucoup l'État est
plus réservé pour tenter de résoudre la
question énergétique et le poids des
dépenses publiques même querelle de
position la réalité est que le niveau de
production ne se décrète pas on le voit
aujourd'hui par cette crise très
preignante et ce qui est important n'est
pas l'objectif annuel mais la structure
de parc que nous souhaitons on atteindre
à terme je pense que c'est une façon de
poser le sujet qui qui est utile pour le
débat public veut-on briser le plafond
de verre des 57 % d'accession et si oui
peut-on le faire avec la politique des
bas revenus que nous avons les
statistiques de Monsieur frigit
apportent des éléments de réflexion
quelle innovation financière concevoir
en ce sens deuxièmement veut-on
continuer la concentration du parc de du
parc locatif privé dans les mains des
ménages multipropriétaires est-ce un bon
choix n'y a-t-il pas là un risque pour
la cohésion sociale enfin veut-on
poursuivre l'effort national pour
développer le logement social qui est le
premier bénéficiaire de la politique du
logement sur le demisècle passé en
croissance en volume je pense que c'est
pas souvent redit en ces termes et dans
quelle direction faire évoluer ce modèle
pour son 2e siècle
d'existence enfin vous m'interrogez sur
les politiques contracycliques
indépendamment du fait évoqué
précédamment que l'État a peu de marge
de manœuvre aujourd'hui clairement une
grande partie des acteurs interprètent
les position du gouvernement comme le
choix résolu d'une régulation
automatique par le marché acceptant les
tensions que cela risque de provoquer
pour les ménag et dans les entreprises
je pense qu'à tout le moins ce choix
s'il est avéré mériterait d'être
explicité mais pour l'avenir veut-on
préserver une marge de sécurité dans le
secteur pour préparer les amortisseurs
réguliers dont il aura immanquablement
besoin tous les 15 ans environ ou
fait-on le choix d'ajustement violent
par le marché enfin vous m'interrogez
sur l'opposition entre lli et plli j'ai
peu d'éléments à à indiquer sinon que le
plli est vraisablement un bon
investissement pour le patrimoine de la
nation à travers le logement social
quant au lli s'il ne coûte pas trop cher
en finance publi c'est un c'est aux
investisseurs d'arbitré par principe
dans une époque financière cependant
troublée je voudrais ajouter un point
complémentaire de façon plus générale le
débat sur le logement d'une certaine
manière tourne en rond du fait de sa
fragmentation qui peut se résumer en
trois grandes approches spécialisées
certes complémentaires mais pas
coordonnées je fais une longue
démonstration de cela dans le livre
logement critique d'une politique
impossible pour faire des propositions
pour le dépasser il il me semble dans le
débat public il y a une très grande
place à la dénonciation du problème du
mallogement une urgence sociale mais qui
est paradoxalement installée sur le
temps long parallèlement nous avons un
travail d'optimisation de l'action
publique qui a euh le revers de se
concentrer sur les détails souvent sur
l'épaisseur du trait et au fond noie le
poisson par une multiplicité de sujets
périphériques à la question centrale du
logement enfin l'approche par le système
de l'habitat plus théorique a l'intérêt
de décrire des processus complexes de
chaînes on parle souvent de chaînne du
logement mais qui sont difficiles à
traduire en
action ce triptique vient en fait de
travaux de recherche des années 90 qui
reposaient la question du logement de
façon avec une très grande acité et qui
qui se sont progressivement spécialisés
dans ces trois voies et il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui l'enjeu est de les
recoordonner de trouver des outils pour
les coordonner ce qui nous aidera
à à faire
cette révolution intellectuelle sur la
politique du logement vous avez situé la
la la référence de la grande réforme de
77 je pense que c'est vraiment cela
qu'il faut viser j'en termine par
quelques propositions proposition
conjoncturelle je voudrais rappeler que
le secteur du logementmobili est
fortement capitalistique et pour obtenir
des résultats rapides il faut forcément
déplacer très vite beaucoup d'argent
c'est compliqué et cela passe par de
l'innovation financière dans le crédit
immobilier je peux pas aller plus loin
je reprends simplement l'idée de
Christian Topalov dans le logement
histoire d'une politique impossible qui
avait inspiré un peu en réponse le livre
sur la critique d'une politique
impossible deuxième point sur le
logement social sur un registre un peu
disruptif puisque vous êtes ouvert à à
ce type de proposition euh le rapport de
Courson évoqué un impôt des sociétés
dans le logement social cela fait débat
s'il est considéré comme un dispositif
de substitution à la RLS qui est un
dispositif très très complexe pour les
organisme peut-être c'est une piste euh
de souplesse de gestion à examiner je ne
sais pas si c'est une bonne piste mais
je pense que ça mérite mérite d'y
regarder de près d'autant plus que ça
répond à des questions
européennes enfin il semble que les
acteurs soient ouverts à une régulation
du foncier qui est la boîte noire des
prix vous l'avez indiqué Monsieur frigid
donc avancer sur ce point et
certainement une bonne chose sur les
propositions structurelles qui se
renvoient au cœur du du travail
d'analyse que j'ai produit la grande
réforme de 77 à bientôt un demi-siècle
le livre blanc du logement social en 75
avait contribué fortement au débat je
pense qu'il serait bon de s'inscrire
collectivement dans un dans une
disposition d'esprit une logique de
travail qui consiste à préparer
patiemment et méthodiquement le prochain
tournant de la politique du logement en
le pensant comme tel pour cela il est
incontournable de reposer la question
question politiquement sens large cela
implique de dépasser les écueils
identifiés dans le débat public j'ai
essayé d'en pointer
quelques-uns ce que je propose en
réponse à la spécialisation des trois
approches c'est de décomposer
aujourd'hui le sujet en deux approches
complémentaires qui me semble-t- touche
à l'identité de notre nation
premièrement une politique de cohésion
sociale qui doit faire du parcours
résidentiel la preuve du pacte
républicain deuxièmement une politique
urbaine qui doit nous permettre de
relever au la main le défi des
transitions énergétiques et climatiques
en améliorant la qualité du cadre de vie
je fais une démonstration assez longue
pourquoi j'arrive à ces deux éléments
qui sont finalement assez schématiques
l'enjeu est de garantir une capacité de
capitalisation des contributions qui
émanent des différentes positions du
champ du logement ce travail semble
engagé dans votre commission mais doit
se poursuivre également dans d'autres
lieux pour y parvenir il faut si vous me
permettez l'expression muscler les
grandes organisations d'expertise
transvers de haut niveau au sein même
des organisations il y a un enjeu
d'organisation de ce travail en interne
et aussi de coordination du champ du
logement parce qu'il me semble chapater
les l'ensemble des écueils que nous
poitons dans le débat public et celui-ci
doit être être clairement posé comme une
condition pratique de réarmement de la
politique du logement pour reprendre le
terme présent dans notre
actualité je pense que la politique du
logement en France a une chance de
pouvoir s'appuyer sur un secteur
constitué et surtout de faire souvent
l'objet de consensus républicain qui
dépasse leséclivage politique habituel
et je pense qu'il est essentiel
de de se concentrer sur ces éléments là
voilà je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur Rochon
c'était l'un et l'autre très
intéressant je ne sais pas qui souhaite
commencer à poser des questions mesdames
alors
Viviane oui moi je voulais aussi vous
remercier pour vos exposés vraiment
passionnants et qui qui apporte beaucoup
à nous vont apporter beaucoup à notre à
notre travail j'en suis sûr moi j'avais
une deux questions trois questions
peut-être sur la question des
euh des de l'augmentation des taux des
taux des des crédit euh ça a mis un
petit certaines banques ont mis un peu
de temps à comprendre que les taux
augmentaient et dans les et ceux qui
font les prêts dans les des banques j'ai
eu quelques informations sur des banques
qui avaient tardé et donc il ont refait
des prêts encore alors que les taux
augmentai qui ont continué à proposer
des taux à faible taux et à très long
sur du long terme donc et qui se trouve
maintenant du coup un petit peu en
difficulté voilà c'était je j'ai cru de
banques j'ai eu l'information que deux
banques étaient avait un petit peu
continué leur marchand de de crédit
avait continué alors que les taux
augmentai bon euh juste est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment que c'est les taux
l'augmentation des taux va faire baisser
les les les prix peut faire baisser les
prix et ou est-ce que c'est uniquement
euh euh si si le le la la longueur des
prês le la longueur des prêts baisse
aussi voilà est-ce que c'est c'est un
mécanisme qui peut faire faire baisser
les prix vous dites que des gens
attendent beaucoup attendent ne vendent
plus et attendent que les prix remontent
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut ça
peut arriver ou alors où est-ce qu'on
doit nous penser que c'est mieux de
rester avec des taux des taux qui sont
plutôt plutôt haut sur la question de la
donc dont Dominique a beaucoup parlé sur
la question de la du sevrage de la le
logement de la drogue fiscal voilà
est-ce que est-ce que certains de voix
disent aussi compris que le les la les
la défiscalisation fait monter les prix
aussi du coup du du logement du coup du
logement fait monter les prix que que ça
peut être cela et puis sur la la
question euh la plus plus générale sur
euh sur la la la construction
euh sur sur les deux nous nous on pense
aussi que dans le modèle économique du
logement c'est important parce qu'il n'y
a pas que que le le fait de construire
des logements il y a le fait aussi de
faire tout travailler toute une économie
qui est autour du du logement et que là
avec la crise et la baisse de la
construction euh on est dans une dans
nombreuses entreprises qui suite à la
crise aussi financière à la crise du du
covid et puis la crise qui s'en est
suivie qui vont se trouver qui doivent
déjà rembourser les PGE qui doivent
aussi maintenant repartir dans leur dans
les charges sociales et on a été alerté
par de nombreux acteurs de économique
comme quoi des entreprises allaient être
en défaut est-ce que il y a pas des
mesures là à prendre rapid rapidement
pour essayer de faire en sorte de de
relancer au-delà de la vision globale
qu'on peut avoir dans une perspective
assez sur court terme sur le logement de
relancer le la construction de
logement merci personnellement j'ai pas
d'information sur des banques qui
auraient pendant plus longtemps octroyé
des frais bateau c'est pas mon domaine
euh est-ce que est-ce que la la hausse
des taux va faire baisser les prix en
tout cas fait baisser les volumes par le
le phénomène qui est bien connu c'est
qui est que beaucoup de vendeurs sont
pas pressés de vendre et donc attendre
bon mais alors en gros c'est la moitié
pour les ventes de logements anciens et
on on sait de comment constituer cette
moitié hein il y a un tiers des ventes
de logement anciens qui font suite à une
mutation à titre gratuit et la moitié de
ce tiers fait suite rapidement à une
mutation à titre gratuit typiquement
c'est les enfants qui ont besoin de
vendre les logements après le décès des
parents pour se partager les tes eux ils
vendent ils vont baisser les prix rapid
c'est grâce à eux que les que les
transactions continuent de se faire il y
a un deuxième type de
mutation un/ers grosso modo des achats
de logement sont le fait de ménag qui
sont déjà propriétaires de le résidence
principale qui décident d'en changer
donc ils en achètent une puisevendent
l'autre pardon dans les TR qu des cas il
vendent l'autre et dans ce cas-là ça
fait aussi une offre qui est qui qui est
prête à baisser les prix quand vous êtes
pressé quand vous avez déjà acheté un
logement vousz et ça fait la moitié ça
fait la moitié et les autres ils ont
tellement entendu dire que les prix ne
pouvaient que que monter ou dans
l'immobilier quand on attend on s'en
sort toujours qui qu's sont pas pressés
voilà donc la question c'est combien de
temps ça va prendre pour que il passe de
la deuxième catégorie à la
première je je ne sais pas la réponse
dépend énormément de votre prévision de
taux d'intérêt et là ça ça m'amène
à à faire un point vous allez devoir
faire des des propositions euh vos
propositions devront être adapté à
l'état du marché quand elle quand vos
propons commenceront à être appliqué
mettons dans 6 mois ou dans un an bon
que seront les taux d'intérêt dans un an
j'en suis je suis incapable de le dire
sinon je serai milliardaire he vous
aussi et tout serai en or ici donc
euh vous êtes malgré tout obligé de
faire de des hypothèses donc je
peut-être aa-t-il que lorsque vous ferez
vos propositions que vous que vous
fassiez faisons l'hypothèse que faire de
scénarios sur tau d'intérêt
voilà personnellement je je vois pas
trop une baisse des taux d'intérêt bon
mais je peux me tromper je me suis
trompé en 2006 2007 j'avais absolument
pas vu venir les taux d'intérêts qui qui
allaient devenir nul ou négatif et donc
ma prévision en 200627 c'est que les
prix allaient revenir vers le revenu par
ménage seule question c'était dans quel
délai le scénario rapide c'était 5 ans
le scénario long c'était 10 ans je crois
voilà bon c'est pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé
euh donc je ne me demandais pas de faire
des prévisions de taux d'intérêt mais si
les taux d'intérêt restent au niveau ils
sont je vois pas comment les à partir
d'un certain moment les volumes ne
pourraient pas enfin les prix ne
finiraient pas par s'ajuster et les
volumes par partir question c'est
combien de temps et là ça fait appel à
des phénomènes
comportementaux que je connais pas mais
j'aurais tendance à dire toujours si
c'est rapide ça sera 5 ans donc vous
voyez c'est pas instantané bon euh sur
les effets inflationnistes vous
m'interrogz les dépenses fiscales B pour
nous c'est une obsession euh en tant que
service d'audit nous passons une bonne
partie de notre temps à au tié des
politiques publiqu et donc il y a deux
obsessions c'est les effets d'auben qui
consiste à payer les gens pour enfin
subventionner les gens pour qu'ils
fassent quelque chose qu'ils font déjà
et les effets inflationnistes B en
matière de d'aide fiscale
l'investissement locatif il y a eu
l'article tranois bonau qui est qui est
le premier qui soit parti qui a ma
connaissance n'a jamais été invalidé qui
reste valable donc je pense qu'en effet
au vu de ce que la biographie il y a eu
des effets inflationnistes des aides
fiscales à l'investissement locatif
voilà tout ce que je peux vous dire j'ai
pas travaillé personnellement dessus
mais la bibliothèque biographieque que
j'ai vu m'a plutôt convaincu
voilà euh ensuite comment relancer la
construction bon euh les les mesures
vous allez prendre vont dépendre du
niveau des taux d'intérêt donc je
reviens à ce que je disais à l'instant
alors déjà faut pas faut pas prendre des
mesures qui risquent pas trop de de
marché donc je l'ai pas dit mais les
ménages empreunent à peu près 60 % du
montant des achat de logement ça vous ça
peut vous paraître peu mais dans les 40
% différence il y a tous les logements
des ménages qui changent de résidence
principale et qui sont revendus c'est
pour ça qu'on arrive à 60 %. donc en
gros il y a 2 3 ans il y a 2 ans ils
empruntaient 300 milliards aujourd'hui
il doiventpr 150 milliards par an à peu
près quand vous regardez l'effet d'une
hausse de taux d'intérêt de 2 % sur des
sommes de cet ordre il suffit de 2 % de
hausse des taux pour annihiler les
fameux 40 milliards du logement c'est la
la solvabilité qui a été retirée de la
poche des acheteurs par la hausse des
taux est équivalente à la totalité euh
de de des 40 des fameux 40 milliards du
logement donc vous voyez que des mesures
budgétaires sont pas vraiment à
l'échelle je pense voilà même si on vous
dit ça on va être très malin on vaê
faire du Smart euh ça il y a des gens
qui vous expliquent qu'on peut faire des
choses très smart je crois que c'est pas
à l'échelle euh alors faut surtout pas
endetter davantage les ménages euh des
fois j'entends des gens dire mais il
faudrait que les gens puissent emprunter
sur 30 ans au lieu d'emprunter sur 2 je
trouve je pense ce serait catastrophique
ça aurait été tellement mieux B on on a
des on a des taux d'intérêt de des taux
d'usure ça aurait été tellement mieux si
on avait interdit de prêter à plus de 20
ans en 2000 voilà maintenant c'est un
peu facile de le dire hein euh voilà
alors euh donc
euh bon il y a il y a une première chose
parce qu'on est au Sénat ici je dirais
c'est c'est donner l'exemple parce que
je pense aux collectivités local une
partie importante du foncier sur lequel
les logements sont construits provient
de la sphère publique euh donc là faut
pas hésiter à mettre ce foncier à à à
vendre ce foncier et à un prix qui
permett au aux promoteurs de sortir des
logements à un prix compétitif ça veut
dire qu'il faut sérieusement baisser les
prix par rapport à ce que les les
propriétaires état ou collectivités
locales pouvaient espérer il y a 2 ans
voilà mais il faut réviser
complètement donc la méthode des
comparaisons par exemple doit être
adaptée pour tenir compte du fait que
entre une mutation qui a eu lieu il y a
2 ans et aujourd'hui et bien les taux
d'intérêt ont énormément augmenté puis
les construction peut-être aussi voilà
donc la première chose c'est donner
l'exemple ça me para important parce que
ça crée des références qui ensuite
peuvent entraîner le reste donc la
sphère publique ne V ne vend qu'une
partie minoritaire du foncier construit
mais elle peut donner l'exemple bon mais
autrement c'est la des prix hein qui
peut ramener le marché aux jours heureux
où on devenait propriétaire en 15 ans il
y a 25
ans sur la défiscalisation peut-être ce
qu'on peut dire
pour commenter cette assertion de drogue
fiscale c'est que vous l'avez noté
depuis plusieurs décennies nous avons ce
dispositif là on peut questionner son
efficacité mais il fait partie des
outils importants et donc les les
arrêter ou les remettre en cause au
moment où nous avons une crise
économique qui n'est pas qui vient pas
du logement en fait qui vient d'éléments
beaucoup plus MACR je je comprends pas
bien la logique et je pense ça mérite
d'être interrogé voilà c'est juste ça je
voudrais juste en commentaire aussi
indiquer que les éléments
desfiscalisation donc vont dans la
construction des prix du logement et il
ont le défaut d'influencer souvent la
composition des programmes parfois
on on peut voir des programmes dont la
typologie la forme est optimisée par
pour optimiser l'avantage fiscal et ça
c'est un biais en fait technique dans la
mise en pratique de ces outils qui est
connu donc qui a regardé aussi de près
puisque c'est pas seulement des éléments
financiers il y a une traduction dans la
ville qui dure ensuite des dizaines
d'années quand on construit un logement
et c'est ça qui qui est très important
avoir à l'esprit de quand quand on
travaille sur ces
dispositifs
Amel merci madame la Présidente encore
un grand merci à vous pour vos exposé
mené au pas de course pour tout vous
dire mais tellement riche dommage que
nous ayons aussi peu de temps mais nous
onons certainement l'occasion de de
reparler de tout cel parce qu'il y a des
choses très concrètes dans ce que vous
avez dit et et qui moi m'ont interpellé
je vais m'adresser d'abord à vous
monsieur frigit concernant un postulat
qui est de dire que la situation
actuelle en fait du logement s'explique
en tout cas sa chireté essentiellement
par le contexte inflationniste de
l'environnement financier euh Viviane
vient d'évoquer hein les taux d'intérêt
forcément c'est c'est une question qui
revient souvent vous avez personne ne
sait aujourd'hui la façon dont ils
évolueront mais vous avez raison en
parlant de scénaris de scénarios
intéressants peut-être à poser et si
demain comme cela est annoncé
aujourd'hui les taux d'intérêt venaient
à être stabilisés pas forcément baissés
mais à stabilisé quel impact cela aurait
et puis euh et parimement à quelle
échéance vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
de baisse et donc d'une échéance à ans
donc est-ce que si on part sur des taux
qui seraient stabiliser euh cette option
tiendrait parce que la grande question
là et nous avons aujourd'hui des voilà
certains se position disons que fin 2024
si on restait sur des taux comme ceci
hein c'est une hypothèse qui nous a déjà
été exprimée ici dans le cadre de nos
auditions dans un an nous aurions déjà
des effets sur sur le marché du logement
j'ai été aussi euh personnellement
fortement interpellé par ce que vous
avez évoqué en terme de popérisation des
locataires euh notamment de des jeunes
des jeunes particulièrement touchés euh
d'un point de vue macro euh donc vous
avez dressé le constat une explication
mais quel moyen quel levier est-ce que
demain mettre en place des politique
ciblé auprès de ces publics serait une
solution selon vous faut-il le faire
parce que il y a les chiffres et puis il
y a euh la cohésion sociale dont nous
sommes aussi garants et nous sommes bien
sûr garants des chiffres puisque que les
deux sont très liés pour pour pouvoir
mener nos politiques publiques mais
est-ce qu'il serait judicieux d'avoir en
tout cas une aujourd'hui en urgence une
politique ciblée auprès de ce public là
puis enfin vous l'avez dit il faut que
les prix baissent quid de l'impacte des
réglementations aujourd'hui sur
notamment le foncier le fameux objectif
du Zéro artificialisation nette est-ce
qu' aujourd'hui vous avez des éléments
sur l'impact que cela pourrait avoir euh
et puis la lutte pour les poirs
thermiques parce que pareillement on
peut faire fi même dans le contexte
économique de ces réglementation qui
dont on parle beaucoup mais qui
peut-être certainement auront un impact
quel est votre avis là-dessus monsieur
Rochon je continue dans les questions et
puis je vous laisserai y répondre en
tout cas n nous apporter vos éclairages
alors vous avez parler et pareilence
j'ai trouvé ça très très vraiment aussi
très intéressant d'une politique très
silencieuse la politique du logement qui
est une politique très silencieuse ici
au Sénat lorsqu'on l'exprime je pense
que là-dessus on partage complètement on
parle d'un manque de cap en fait d'un
manque de cap sur sur sur la politique
logement et qui en fait aujourd'hui et
vous l'avez dit de façon très très
claire hein qui est aujourd'hui une
politique qui est tout c'est une
politique qui est tout sauf politique en
fait et c'est là où ça peut être
vraiment une source d'inquiétude compte
tenu de l'état de cohésion j'ai parler
de cohésion sociale mais de notre pays
euh sans revenir voilà sur justement
l'état dans lequel se trouve notre pays
hein de de
division quelle serait pour vous votre
quelle est votre vision des choses par
rapport à cela vous avez évoquer
quelques pistes mais des pistes plutôt
ciblées moi j'aimerais bien avoir votre
regard plus macro sur l'approche qu'on
pourrait avoir pour dessiner cette
future grande
politique logement et euh oui ce qui est
indéable aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est que
c'est vraiment une source de fracture
sociale donc est-ce que ça veut dire
derrière vous l'avez évoqué il y a une
vraie réflexion à mener sur le parcours
résidentiel et je je lis en fait cette
réflexion là à ce qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire ces jeunes qui sont
particulièrement touchés aussi sur cette
sur cette sur cette politique vous avez
évoqué bon je je le dis parce que
pareiment j'ai réagi là-dessus et je
pense qu'on est nombreux à le partager
hein l'ancien ministre qui a
clairement annoncé pas annoncé qui
défend une une vision très
territoriale de de la politique logement
vision que sur certains aspects on peut
partager lorsqu'on parle de
différenciation territoriale mais là où
je vous rejoins complètement c'est que
ça ne peut pas nous exonérer d'une
vision nationale très
concrètement j'en viens au sujet de
l'organisation est-ce qu'il y a selon
vous des sujets qui doivent justement
rester euh être traité uniquement au
niveau national et là je pense que vous
comprenez que je je fais le lien avec
les les discussion que nous avons
aujourd'hui beaucoup sur notre
organisation l'organisation de la
politique logement et des du grand sujet
autour de la décentralisation donc
qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui doit
nécessairement rester ou revenir ou
rester aux mains aux mains de de l'État
et enfin sur les aides fiscal j'ai
terminé là-dessus quantitativement vous
dénoncez vous exprimez le manque de
résultats euh des aides fiscales hein
vous le dites en terme de de je l'aurais
dit bien quantitativement maintenant la
question peut se poser d'un point de vue
qualitatif c'est-à-dire tout ce que
amène finalement ces aides fiscales euh
est-ce qu'il ne s'agit pas en fait d'un
moyen
essentiel d'accession ou d'ascenseur en
fait social et est-ce que finalement on
ne doit pas faire attention dans les
choix ou les décisions
que nous devons prendre à intégrer aussi
cette
dimension sociale sociétale extrêmement
importante je vous
remercie bien je vais essayer de
répondre à certaines de vos questions la
première fait stabilisation des taux
d'intérêt si les taux d'intérêt par
rapport au niveau extrêmement bas où il
étaient descendu augmente de 3 % se
stabilise à plus 3 % ça enlève presque
30 % de capacité d'achat donc il faut
que les les prix qui étaient montés
baissent de 30 % moins l'augmentation du
revenu par ménage pendant le même temps
mais l'augmentation du revenu par ménage
sauf si jamais il y avait reprise de
l'inflation chose que personnellement je
je ne ENF je suis pas non plus un de
mais j'ai pas l'impression en tout cas
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat j'y
crois pas vu les tas de choses qui les
tas de problèmes qu'on r compre donc il
pourrait y avoir qu'une reprise
d'inflation qui est pas que ce qui est
pas mon hypothèse au-delà des 2 %
objectif de la Banque centrale
européenne donc en 3 ans ça ferait 6 %
donc l'essentiel devrait venir d'une
baisse d'une baisse des prix si si la
hausse des taux se stabilise à + 3 pour
qu'on revienne à la situation antérieure
de marché ayant la même fluidité
autrement dit où le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages serait serait le même il
faudrait une baisse de cet ordre dans
quel délai je sais pas en en 2006 200007
je disais euh le seul modèle qu'on estit
c'est ce qui s'est passé à Paris modèle
récent ce qui s'est passé à Paris en
90 on a commencé par monter puis ensuite
on n pas eu de parachute contrairement à
ce qui s'est passé ici en 2009 où la
banque centrale est venue prix donc on
est retombé et on est redescendu à la
vitesse à laquelle on est monté et vous
voyez c'est c'est pas très scientifique
ce que je vous dis là donc j'aurais
tendance à dire qu'il faudrait la même
durée pour descendre que pour monter
c'est pas je je sais pas vraiment
répondre à votre question la deuxième
question la poupérisation des jeunes les
problèmes de la politique du logement
c'est qu'on subit les conséquences de
phénomènes qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
logement popérisation des jeunes n pas
n'est pas un phénomène d'origine
logement est-ce qu'il faut ou non une
politique ciblée je ne sais pas j'ai pas
réfléchi à la question l'effet des
réglentation sur les prix alors les
réglementation en effet sur les prix de
construction dans 20 ou 30 ans quand on
se demandera ce que la France a fait de
de la MAN céleste que la banque centrale
a déversé sur elle en abaissant les taux
d'intérêt enfin en déversant sur une
partie d'entre elles parce que les
épargn n'ont pas bénéficié cette man
c'était plutôt l'inverse pour eux euh et
ben on se on on se rendra compte qu'en
matière de logement l'essentiel est
parti en inflation c'est pas perdu pour
tout le monde hein parce que les
vendeurs nets ont été les grands
gagnants c'estàd les personnes âgées on
retend encore une fois les personnes
âgées qui sont gagnant les les les
jeunes se sont endettés sur 25 ans sur
23 ans au lieu de 15 et pendant ce
temps-là les vendeurs nets qui sont les
personnes âgées ça c'est bien c'est bien
identifié ont bénéficiit euh de
l'équivalent de de 6 mois de revenus
disponibles des ménages c'était une man
céleste et donc leur consommation c'est
bien porté le marché des croisières
c'est très bien porté
bon donc quand on se demandera ce qu'on
a fait de tout ça une grande partie est
partie en effet inflationniste et c'est
traduit par de la consommation ce qui
est ce qui est une aberration une partie
bon c'était pas le cas sur les HLM les
HLM on un régime tout à fait à part et
alors une autre partie probablement à
financer la les hausses desnmes de
construction en ce sens que comme il y
avait
comme les ménages av la capacité de
payer beaucoup
plus quand on quand on augmente les
normes de construction alors que la
capacité des ménages est constante faut
que les vendeurs de terrain baissent
leur prix d'utant pour les transactions
continu faire et ça c'est pas facile à
obtenir par contre quand il y a un effet
haussier général ça veut dire simplement
que la hausse du prix des terrains était
un peu plus faible que ce qu'on aurait
pu attendre voilà donc je pense que une
quand on fera le bilan not an on se dira
tiens on a payé pendant cette P là une
partie de la transition écologique
disons si on considère que Nord
supplémentaire de la transition
écologique avec la baisse des taux et ça
c'est pas une aberration en soi c'est
pas une
aberration c'est un investissement sur
le long terme on peut
dire mais ça c'est prix de construction
les prix de vente des logements anciens
ne sont pas déterminé par les de
construction c'est c'est indépendant bon
les partoir thermi je' je n'ai rien à
dire sur ce sujet j'ai pas
étudié alors sur le ce que vous
qualifiez de manque de cap je je dirais
que ces dernières années peut-être on a
on a pour l'interpréter hein on a fait
l'hypothèse que au fond la politique du
logement pouvait se résumer à un sujet
technique avec des boîtes à outils et
euh pourquoi pas mais la réalité
d'aujourd'hui montre que euh cette boîte
à outils ne permet pas de prévenir les
crises et ne permet pas de les traiter
donc ça remonte ça redevient un sujet
politique on pouvait faire cette
expérience historique de regarder
comment ça se passe si on est uniquement
dans le technique bon ben je pense pense
que c'est la conclusion c'est que non on
peut pas continuer dans dans cette
direction là mais donner un cap évident
tout de suite ça me paraît compliqué
puisqueau fond il y a une perte de
savoir-faire dans l'élaboration de cette
de ce cap là c'est pas seulement une
incantation en fait c'est un travail à
produire moi c'est c'est ça en fait ma
ma conviction profonde donc forcément ça
met un petit peu de
temps je crois aussi que la situation
présente montre que la crise est valable
pour la France pas seulement pour
certains territoirees et donc on a de
fait une politique nationale puisque là
on est confronté à une crise immobilière
et du logement qui est générale donc
ça cela signifie en miroir que la
politique du logement elle doit se
préparer à ce type d'événements qui sont
quand même relativement récurrents sur
un pas de temps assez long euh
et moi il me semble que le le débat sur
la structure du parc est important parce
que on a beaucoup débattu il y a un peu
plus de 20 ans avec la loi sus sur sur
la place qu'on devait donner au logement
social j'ai indiqué que on a quand même
ce succès majeur d'avoir 5 millions de
logements sociaux c'est c'est vraiment
une chance mais c'est aussi un élément
la structure du parc qui est composé du
locatif privé et de l'accession et je
pense que maintenant on arrive après un
quart de siècle de la loisu à un moment
où il serait intéressant de regarder
l'équilibrage de l'ensemble et pas
seulement cbler sur le logement social
qui est un succès faut peut-être
continuer à le développer mais avoir une
vision beaucoup plus
je pense que ça ça peut apporter des
choses et on sait pas trop le faire
encore et sur les aides
[Applaudissements]
fiscal on revient en fait sur les
limites de la politique du logement et
dans les années 90 on a bien identifié
que et bien la politique du logement
aussi était mise en défaut avec cette
avec le la la remise en scène du de du
de l'abbé Pierre en fait après 54 il
revient les années 90 parce qu'on
retrouve une crise du logement pourquoi
et bien parce qu'on a un problème d'une
partie de la population qui s'est
précarisé et la conséquence est le
problème du logement mais on peut pas le
résoudre par la politique du logement
puisque le problème est en amant moi
j'ai toujours cru enfin j'ai longtemps
cru que la que la politique du logement
avait des effets en cascade au fond si
on résout la politique du logement on
résout le problème d'échec scolaire de
tout un ch chose en en en cascade par
suite aujourd'hui je pense plutôt à
l'inverse par que la politique du
logement agit dans un réseau de
contrainte de la situation sociale qui
lui échappe en très grande partie et
donc on a réussi à améliorer très
consididérablement depuis les années 70
la qualité du parc de logement des
Français c'est c'est c'est quand même un
résultat tout à fait significatif on a
globalement des beau logements qui sont
grands on peut critiquer un petit peu
bon on a eu tout ce travail
d'amélioration qui était pensé à partir
des 70 où on s'est dit on a résolu le le
déficit de construction on va travailler
sur l'amélioration de la qualité
aujourd'hui après une cinquantaine
d'années on a d'autres sujets qui sont
la la transition écologique c'est le
grand sujet d'avenir pour le logement et
on
a ce ce problème de
euh tenter de dépasser les limites de la
politique du logement par le constat des
difficultés sociales qui qui voilà
peut-être qu'il y a un enjeu de de
retrouver d'inventer de nouvelles marges
de manœuvre qu'on a qui n'étit pas les
sujets des des dernières décennie pour
le dire de façon très euh intuitive
comme ça
hein merci peut-être juste encore deux
questions de ma part euh comment est-ce
que vous voyez l'avenir de l'accession à
la
propriété et puis euh comment et dans
quel délai pensez-vous qu'il pourrait
avoir de nouveau un marché de
l'immobilier qui soit de nouveau qui
retrouve une certaine
fluidité
bon sur sur le premier
point les le le pourcentage de propriét
occupant et à peu près stabilisé à 58 %
oui c'est ça pas à 62 comme le disent
certaines comparaisons internationales
euh en France
euh par contre sur pour certaines
personnes sur certaines cl d'âge à 40
ans peuvent dire
qu' le pour certaines classes d'âge le
taux de propriét occupe pendant 40 ans
est 10 % plus faible que ce qu'était
ceux de leurs parents c'est-à-dire que
cette stabilisation est très
différenciée selon le profil une fois de
plus je suis désolé c'est encore les
personnes âgées qui sont gagnantes mais
là il y a des classes d'âge moyen force
de l'âge où le taux de propriétoccupant
a vraiment baissé et on peut comprendre
que c'est personne a un sentiment
d'éclassement d'ailleurs je me compare
mes parents ben je vois que je ah ils
étaient propriétairesage là pas moi bon
comment je vois
l'avenir j'ai l'impression que le taux
moyen de 58 est pas aberrant
parce qu'il faut tout il faut tous les
marchés différents types de marché j'ai
pas l'impression que ça puisse ça vaille
la peine de viser plus haut
ensuite quand vous demandez combien de
temps faudra--il on retombe sur la
question tout à l'heure commencez par
faire une prévision de taux d'intérêt et
ensuite une fois que vous avez fait
votre prévision de taux d'intérêt
demandez-vous combien de temps il faudra
pour que les prix baissent au niveau
permis par le par les taux d'intérêt et
on n pas beaucoup d'expérience
antérieure il a fallu Fall seulement 5
ans pour que les prix augmentent de 70 %
si on descend à la même vitesse faudrait
5 ans pour que les prix baissent de 30
%. je je pense si les taux d'intérêt ne
baisse pas on est parti pour plusieurs
années de contraction des volumes voilà
j'en sais pas plus
merci sur l'accession peut-être on on
pourrait indiquer que quand on a imaginé
la réforme de 77 ou dans dans cette
époque un petit peu lointaine maintenant
euh l'idée que le logement était aussi
un patrimoine financier et aussi quelque
chose qu'on pouvait transmettre
n'existait pas on était dans une autre
époque où ce qu'il fallait c'est trouver
des solutions pour que les gens soient
correctement logés et amélior leurs
conditions de vie aujourd'hui il me
semble qui est très installé dans dans
la population une aspiration à la
propriété qui n'est pas seulement
technique pour obtenir un logement plus
grand ou avec d'autres aménités qu'on a
pas forcément dans un logement locatif
mais qui a aussi une visée financière
euh comme si voilà cette France de
propriétaire c'était une France voilà
qui qui se pr qui qui se voit comme un
investisseur hein avec cette figure de
de l'entrepreneur qui est très présente
aujourd'hui en France et donc ça c'est
quelque chose totalement nouveau par
rapport au demiiècle passé et dont on ne
peut pas ne pas tenir
compte qu'on soit pour ou contre hein
voilà je pense que c'est un élément très
important un complément de revenu pour
les c'est le logement qui fait la
référence c'est voilà c'est que on on on
on a réussi à faire du logement non
seulement le lieu d'habitation et il est
devenu un véritable actif à l'échelle de
ménage qui dans les
qui ne visait pas une épargne une
capitalisation il y a quelques dizaines
d'années c'était pas le projet de
société qu'on avait aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est très incrusté dans notre
projet de société donc ça il faut le
travailler quoi
voilà très bien question
sur un seul
point juste revenir sur un seul point
vous avez évoqué d'ailleurs à deux
reprises dans dans dans votre exposé en
préambule le manque de
savoir-faire pour penser
élaborer la future vision du logement le
logement de demain d'aujourd'hui et de
demain qu'entendez-vous par savoir-faire
est-ce que c'est la capacité à mobiliser
des données donc sur tous les sujets de
données fibles ou est-ce qu'il s'agit de
d'une organisation ou d'une volonté tout
simplement qui n'est pas alimenté donc
par des ressources pour le faire merci
je alors je pense pas que ce soit un
problème de de de volonté parce que j'ai
dit qu'on avait un secteur qui est bien
organisé
mobilisé je crois que aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus de partis politiques qui
sont des laboratoires d'idées à l'époque
j'ai pris l'exemple de jaces Chirac le
Prato zéro c'était tout un travail qui
était fait en amont par Pierre-André
Perissol qui lui-même était acteur
logement élu et donc ça c'est ça c'est
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas une
concertation qui est une forme
d'engagement politique et aujourd'hui
notre secteur il a la la force d'être
très
professionnalisé mais on est dans une
société aujourd'hui où la
transposition de l'analyse de terrain en
projet politique et bien c'est quelque
chose je suis désolé mais que qu'on ne
sait plus trop faire ou qu'on a perdu de
vue et et pourtant c'est passionnant
enthousiasment et les laboratoires
d'idées qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui en fait produisent assez peu
de choses sur la question du logement ou
assez rapide et c'est quand même assez
long à faire voilà
oui et puis on voit peut-être que ça se
déplacé que ce sont plus tellement les
partis politiques qui met plutôt des in
enfin des qui qui prennent le relais
après cela vient aussi oui on a presque
fini monsieur cela vient aussi peut-être
du fait que depuis malheureusement pas
mal d'années le logement n'est jamais
n'est plus considéré comme une priorité
on le voit dans le casadre des
différentes campagnes qui ont pu avoir
lieu voilà c'est c'est jamais au cœur
des des principaux débats qui sont
portés sur le devant de la scène
politique et je crois pouvoir dire tout
parti politique
confondu c'est c'est aussi le ce vide
don dont je parlais là mais qui qui est
au fond une page blanche pour sauter un
oui on n pas obligé de s'incrire dans
uneé une crique de ce qui s fait moi je
pense qu'on peut justement entrer dans
le sujet assez directement donc c'est
pas une opportunité mais en tout cas
c'est une occasion de regarder les
choses et bien merci beaucoup messieur
pour vos interventions et voilà toutes
ces ces idées que vous avez porté
maintenant à notre réflexion et on vous
souhaite une bonne fin de journée une
bonne soirée
merci